hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to meta we've got tiny
box Tim here and we've got a forbidden
key which is supposedly gonna lead us
down to a dark and dangerous place
filled with death and despair and also
there's an entity stop stabbing him in
the butt Tim oh but I wanna he's dead
already you'll have plenty to satiate
your blood thirst soon oh I gotta leave
tiny bucks Tim behind but I do think
that the developer uh put them in here
for a reason use it a chest
you didn't look just I'll be back you be
good I just gotta go to a forbidden
place oh right sorry team first yes bye
I wonder what a whoa whoa that's
actually quite terrifying
well good stretch my favorite word Tim's
not here hello monster
alright then did he actually Teufel way
or did he just turn invisible because
one of those options is very bad
alrighty then is anybody you know here
anybody alright then
somebody need to do with that softly go
I was about to say it's awfully quiet
let me just touch the live sparking
cables I'm sure that'll be good for me
we still end the torment of my existence
here soon enough
good is this like descending into the
future arm is like radioactive pool soon
as I go down here I'm gonna be mutated
into a horrible creature like them
gurgle smeargle samson's uh Kirkland
hello oh good yeah okay that's suddenly
got I suddenly got a million types of
cry fear vibe somebody's look like
half-life one textures okay alright then
oh hi you alright you look normal and
fun okay I am so sorry so am i no wonder
this place is called forbidden let's go
towards the giant blood trail oh god
that's a dead end is that handprint
always there oh wait a minute wait a
minute giant blood spatter handprint ah
you changing up on me huh you being a
bit of a douche
what do you ever
oh yeah for me what do you got for me
nothing okay
I'm gonna trust you on this one that guy
cut in half
am I still looping back to the places
I've been before because I don't
remember where I've been uh that's a fun
looking one oh god a dead end
oh good okay all right okay
Oh sky no no no no no no Nona
I've come to be your friend I'm the only
one that can understand you we
communicate and learn to be besties for
the rest of the game good thing to know
that flies are down here okay way out
good I trust this whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa okay all right okay I'm not
moving
oh I thought I'd be moving okay I've
never seen that done in amnesia before I
know he was moving in the walls and uh
no no no no it was a mistake coming down
here oh it was a big hello baby oh I
know it was you the whole time I
would've been so scared
good baby oh boy that does not look fun
okay okay what the hell whoa whoa there
ease up there sunny Jim what the Flippa
flab what is that all about huh oh
you're weird
you're like a baby but you're crawling
what is this all about huh I don't know
I'm out here I'm out here I'm out here
with that pass [ __ ] father nutters yeah
okay am I supposed to lead you in the
air so that you get grabbed up good
right Hey all right okay
do not die good advice
sage advice from the master of Emmys I'm
sure all right so where is he where is
it
Oh is he gone now is he gone now what is
with you you weirdo but oh that was not
there before maybe I was supposed to
wear as it was it was it where's the
wisdom with with her okay
I'll just be on my way I've got the
writhing trees hi I'm mr. phh's No
okay okay okay
it's my baby
grime our your then yeah I dread Bobby
whoa did not expect to actually be there
don't we go old break
that's exactly what I did and want okay
all right we're okay
brookey we're okay hello baby faces good
see you again I gotta sing by me all
right
is it still by me jump okay did I ask up
a oh I escaped from that
who's Tim who's Tim Tim Tim Tim
television Tim OH
how in the world did I get out from a
sewer surrounded by baby faces all
righty then okie dokie all right
am I in a graveyard whoo all right not
yet not yet not yet not yet oh hi what
is that is that supposed to be what do I
have a choice game save the story ends
here for now proceeding forward of
classic game until the sequel will be
made to see the credits enter the red
light okay
ah I don't believe you what if it's a
trick
what if it's a trick what if it really
does lead somewhere
I have to know after no I probably just
crashes the game it right the product is
scarlet credits to play it safe I'll
come back afterwards oh the end well
that was actually surprising in a lot of
ways I think surprising is the best way
to describe that because oh the main
protagonist ended imprisoned in
forbidden section not knowing if he is
living or dead
will he get out of the pit of death that
was created by foolish conspirators that
yearn for power express your opinion if
this should have a sequel meta full
conversion mod made by uma karna creator
of destiny rebellion I gotta say though
you know when I comparing this in
Destiny's rebellion I definitely see the
total strangeness of it there's a lot of
things thrown in that are from different
parts and areas that are still pretty
cool like it made for a good story but
you know I felt like there are some
things lacking in in this SOI that could
have been made better I mean one for one
the story never made any sense when I
was going through it like I was just a
reporter in a dungeon but I didn't feel
like I was unraveling the mysteries of
what this guy was actually doing like
was he the leader of all this but when I
went through the place everyone seemed
dead because of what they did like there
was no one that was actually alive
throughout the whole thing so I'm
assuming that everyone was just broken
down by their own hubris so what in the
world happened like that's the question
like what is going on in this world
obviously there's like some secret
society of assassins that are supposed
to take down the people that need to be
taken down I guess but still it's a
little weird I don't know but either way
it got me a few times it was definitely
scary in some moments some moments were
less scary and more funny or silly but
either way it was still a lot of fun I
liked it a lot it had a custom
soundtrack there was a ton of custom
work put into it it's still all around
for a custom story that is a full
conversion mod and totally free feel
pretty good I would give it a thumbs up
you guys should play definitely play it
there may be some other stuff that I
didn't see in here because I was rushing
in a blind panic or I wasn't paying
attention to things around me like there
were
you locked doors and few other doors
that I didn't take so maybe there's
something I didn't see that you guys can
find for yourself so thank you again
everybody for watching thank you guys
for making this one thank you in boo
karna for creating it and as always oh
wait no there's gonna be it there's a
ton there's a ton a ton a ton of custom
story mods that are available in the
description below I played so many em
these customs to a some fantastic some
silly some funny all worth your time so
check them out in the description below
or the link in the annotation over there
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye okay let's see if this really
does crash my game I'm willing to bet it
does but who knows yep it crashed whoo
whoo whoo okay here we go y'all ago I
got the looks and the brain to play
games like this Oh
record and Fox